(cop show music)
- You're a naughty little girl,
and then I get closer to
the golden pot of honey,
and finally, when you're--
Finally my partner gives
me the wrap up sign,
so I blow my load in your face
and leave without
saying goodbye.
- This is car 67,
- we're code five,
- code five,
- nothing to report.
- we've got nothing to report.
(saxophone)
(coughing)
(sigh)
(heavy sigh)
- What is your problem?
- I'm kinda having
a rough night here.
- No a rough night is
sitting her for hours
listening to my partner wheeze.
- It's not a wheeze,
it's a sigh, okay.
Denise and I are
having some problems,
and she said she
was gonna call--
- Woah, woah woah woah.
You know the rules, Moses.
No lady problems in the
car, this is a cop car,
this is our office, this
is our place of worship.
- She's my wife, Chance,
it's not just lady problems.
- Okay, listen.
I know all about
lady problems, okay?
No one has more lady problems
than me, and real ones.
- You mean which half
Asian half Mexican model
you're gonna make love to?
- First of all, she's 3/4
Asian, 1/4 Mexican, okay?
Second of all, I don't tell you
a lot of my dating problems.
But since you're
asking, I was dating
this chick a few
months ago, okay.
I took her to Catalina,
romantic getaway,
overnight on the boat.
I woke up in the
morning, she was gone.
- Did you call her?
- Yeah, multiple times.
- She just didn't want
to talk to you Chance.
- No that's impossible, no,
that's not how it works.
- When she got to Catalina, she
took another ferry, and left.
- No...
- This isn't a hard thing to
figure out, you're a detective.
- She didn't get off the
boat, this is like a mystery.
- Have you done
anything to solve it?
- I tried, I sent her a text.
- Okay, you wanna
hear real problems,
that I really have,
in my real life?
- What are those?
- My son calls me
Officer Packard.
Not daddy, not father,
not even Moses.
Officer Packard.
- Oh, you mean your
son who loves you
and respects the fact
that you're a cop?
- He says if I hurry up and
get shot in the line of duty,
he can finally stop
lying to his teachers
about take your
parents to school day.
- Okay, how about this?
I lost my virginity at
12 to a six-foot-four
field hockey chick.
Big, beefy, domineering,
I had no experience
so I just did what I was told,
and I assumed that's
how sex worked.
- So you're still?
- Yeah, I don't do a thing,
unless the girl tells me to.
- I would love that,
I would love that.
You know why?
- Why?
- My shrink tells me
I'm a sexual illiterate.
- What does that even mean?
- It means I can't
read sexual cues,
resulting in a
confused erection.
- Oh that's just
made up and stupid.
- Why don't you ask my wife
about my funeral boners?
Then tell me if it's
made up and stupid.
- Why should I ask your
wife, I don't respect women
anyways because my mother
never taught me to.
She was a hypochondriac,
locked herself in her room
23 hours, 15 minutes a day.
She'd come out for 45
minutes to eat peanut butter
and banana sandwiches,
and you know what else?
She never hugged me, not once.
She didn't touch me,
didn't caress me,
didn't even give me
a handshake, nothing.
What are you doing?
- I'm trying to
show you my pain.
- Oh you want some pain,
I'll show you some pain.
- You wanna go, you wanna go?
- Yes!
- My dad used to put
cigarettes out on me, right?
This time, he used a cigar.
- But that happens
to kids all the time.
- This was last Christmas.
- Wow.
- He thought I was
acting like a big shot
because I got a great
deal on a new Taurus.
He felt his alpha status
was being threatened, so,
he did this!
- Oh, that's good!
Okay listen to this, I
dropped out of high school,
and lived on the streets,
I was so delusional,
I thought I was living in
someone else's nightmare.
I had to cut myself to
prove I was still alive.
Look, that's for life.
- Cutting? I have
the ultimate cut.
I swore I would do anything
for my college girlfriend, so,
I gave her my kidney!
Yeah, and when she recovered
from her transplant,
she broke up with
me because I wasn't
a whole person anymore.
I haven't been able to
trust a woman since.
I even hide a wad of cash and
a passport at the train depot,
just waiting for my
wife to betray me.
- You've got a bug out bag?
- You don't, what's
wrong with you?
- You wanna know
what's wrong with me?
- Yeah!
- I'll tell you
what's wrong with me!
- Bring it!
- Look at this body, look at
this sculpted, muscular body.
You know why I look like this?
Because I'm alone,
and I have nobody,
so I spend all my
time in the gym,
with my friends the barbells!
- I have an eating disorder!
- I eat my toenails!
- I resent my children!
- I resent your children,
and my children too!
- You don't have any children!
- Well I would if that
girl hadn't disappeared
off the boat in Catalina Island!
One of these days I'm
gonna shot on this street,
and at my funeral, no
one's gonna take my flag
because I have nobody!
- No, I'm gonna take that
flag, I'm gonna take that flag
and put it on my mantle
in my studio apartment
when my family leaves me, and
I'm gonna look at it proud
when your gunned down
by a useless meth head!
- Is that what you're gonna do?
- Yeah!
- Are you sure?
- Yes!
- Really?
(sobbing)
- [Radio] Attention all
units in the vicinity,
700 blocks Franklin Avenue.
We have a 314 in progress,
indecent exposure.
We've got reports of
two men, one overweight.
Suspects are crying and
yelling about crystal meth.
May require
psychiatric assistance.
- This is car 67, we got
everything under control.
We got everything under control.
- Not everything.
- Sorry.
Sexual illiteracy.